في وسط مدينه اضنه وفي الساعه الثالثه بعد
منتصف الليل تواصل فرق الانقاذ البحث عن
ناجين تحت انقاض المباني المدمره هنا في
هذا الشارع المقابل لاحد المباني المدمره
يواصل رجال قدموا من خارج مدينه اضنه الى
هذه المدينه بانتظار اخبار عن ذويهم الذين
هم تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى المدمر الحراره
تحت الصفر تقريبا هناك اشعل النيران وايضا
اخذوا بعض الاغذيه في محاوله لدرء البرد
ساحاول الحديث معهم عن اخبار او ما هي
الاخبار التي ينتظرونها من قبل الفرق
الانقاذ
تحت هذا المبنى المنهار يتواجد ابن اخي
وزوجته واطفاله الثلاثه نحن كالبقيه ننتظر
بقلق شديد انا اليوم جئت الى هنا من
ايضا هناك اشخاص عاشروا او عاشروا الزلازل
القديمه سنسالهم عن رايهم بالفرق بين
الزلزال القديم والزلزال الحادثه اسال
السيد حسن صندوق كنت في اضنه اثناء زلزال
1999 كانت شدته اكثر من 6.5 اما هذا
الزلزال فشدته تجاوزت سبع درجات واستمر
لمده دقيقه وعشرين ثانيه هذا الزلزال اعنف
وكما تابعنا في هذا هذه المقابلات حقيقه
يعني مشاعر متناقضه من جاء من خارج اضنه
الى هذه المدينه لانتظار اخبار ايجابيه
يحاول الصبر والانتظار مهما طال الزمن ما
زال متفائلا هذا الشخص الذي قابلناه
بالوصول الى اخبار ايجابيه وربما لقاء
اقاربهم مجددا وقد خرجوا احياء من تحت
الانقاض ايضا الاشخاص الذين التقيناهم
وسالناهم عن رايهم في الزلزال الفرق ما
بين الزلزال القديم والزلزال الحالي طبعا
يؤكدون ان الزلزال الحال كان اشد واكثر
رعبا واكثر تدميرا من الزلزال السابق
لقناتي العربيه والحدث زيدان زنجلو اضنه